[music] the
hall flew
for you I will sit
[music]
right in front of the lady and in front of me the game of
prisoners
[music]
so much after the shelling of the bridge hail
hit the house
[music]
yes the
factory was killed of course not
tarly at all 2 glasses flew here karl 4
arrival in  butt sign kherson we can
see it to me
spoiled
when
as
if if kherson
a
[music]
[laughter]
sdo space in ukraine
we are whites of the white house
knitting a damn beckoning arch now the
dossier is taking away
[music]
[applause]
today was waiting for our handsome man in general  everyone
[ __ ] ours everyone is just great no one
took us anything and all the full trucks
go back to [ __ ] where they came from
[applause]
ukraine
[music]
mice
[applause]